do you believe God can completely
disappear cease to exist
I believe he can't come answer my
question but also yes I believe he child
could be completely completely I said
cease to exist to exist and all sex at
the same time I believe that
I believe he can be completely
completely I said cease to exist
histories and all sex at the same time I
believe that
well that's the paradox do you know why
that's the pattern oh I believe that no
do I believe that no wait wait he's
hiding oh you finished you finished are
you telling me Gianni thank God okay
I've done you just read a straight I'm a
limited me
you made unlimited B I've done sell him
or not can I say can I say something now
you don't think you can I say something
you just made a claim you made a claim
that God can cease to exist and exist at
the same time you're under that weight
be honest I know you don't know why did
you say one because let's say Plus why
did you say my and we said I'm telling
you I laid brothers in this way I'm
gonna say it you know coo coo mama
chichi did you understand what a hawk
can ask I spoke the truth I spoke the
truth
you just made a statement you don't
understand why would you use that
Stillson against me when you don't
understand you said you know one can
cease to exist and not exist at the same
time yeah exist a simple yes you know
why yes do you understand what we have
another standoff Phyllis okay you don't
answer so why did you have to buy good
sorry SFC about God I understand this
much that God cannot do you understand
everything about God no not everything
same as me I understand what I'm saying
I understand what I'm saying I am saying
God kill only Zionists an order cannot
hold it I understand with a meal another
letter no but you said God can exist and
not exist at the same time where did you
get that from where did you get that
from and do you understand it well
understand applause where did you get
that from
I'm the Bible
where does the Bible said the God can
exist in see strictures Bible this Bible
see that Bible Bible doesn't have I know
that by using shuffle if I tell and I do
everything know was how you do
everything with digress everything I do
everything that reason I just want to
tell you every change you cannot do
every can't believe that yeah I don't
powerful yes okay can do every talking
what's the question hand good make a
stone yeah look God is made the Sophia
and his channel if he goes this is too
heavy
okay can go do that you can't do
everything God can do everything the
reasons reading it to the end why you
have to make garden turn God into a cat
and a monkey and an elephant and a man
is because you believe in a man as God
that's why we don't have to go through
that rubbish we don't have to defend God
in that way because God has told us that
God cannot do impossibilities God cannot
cease to be God so you can go if it's
God if God ceases to be God then he is
no God
shoo-shoo shoo-shoo